before you begin building the tRNA make
sure you have the template scissors and
tape cut out each piece leaving the gray
tabs and tap
step two
following the nucleotide numbering tape
the pieces into a long strip the blank
great task should be hidden make slits
in between each double line there 16
total be careful enough to cut through
the entire strip
step four fold back in a mountain fold
on the horizontal dashed lines
fold in a valley fold formation on the
small vertical dotted lines
step 6
bring color or pattern sections together
and tape so the gray tab is hidden it is
important that you match the bases in
the following order faces 10 to 13 shall
be alive was twenty five to twenty two
faces 27 to 31 should be aligned goes 43
to 39 this was 49 to 53 should be
aligned the 65 to 61 and basis 1 to 7
should be aligned with 72 to 66 notice
the almost perfect base pairing g2c and
80 new bases pair up at this point the
model is a clover leaf shape the
secondary structure of tRNA each colored
region represents a double helical
regions of the structure step 7 bring
together bases t19 and c-56 colored
yellow to form a base pair hide the grey
tab by taping it under this forms the
beginnings of the tRNA tertiary
structure the inverted l-shape for more
information about tRNA this is the RC
SBPD b101 website at our CSV or PDB 101